I really want you to meet a fine lady
who is going to be the movies breakout
star
she literally steals every single scene
that she's in get ready Tiffany Haddish
well I look like a bedazzler threw up on
that thing the first two weeks that we
were filming it was like a dream come
true for me so I would go back to my
hotel room and be crying like it'd be
odd thank you you may have seen Tiffany
in TV shows and movies like Keanu with
key and Peele and she's also a
successful stand-up comedian a lot of
people say Tiffany why do you do comedy
you so pretty and I'm like girl please I
got a lazy eye and I can't read that
good girls trip the 37 year old always
seems to get in the last line heavenly
finally I want to thank you for this day
in life and let me get pregnant by
somebody rich that's all ass how much
fun did you have making this movie to be
able to discover yeah and bring forth a
new talent like Tiffany it's everything
there's that Chaka Zulu right there
Tiffany says her sense of humor comes
from surviving a very tough childhood
which included growing up in three
different foster homes I was just a kid
David I could after everything she's
been through
Tiffany still has to pinch herself to
believe she's co-starring in a comedy
with some of her idols it's super fun
and like when I say something funny and
they laugh I was like
[Music]
you